CLAIRE SHIPMAN: Katty and I, my
co-author and I, were struck.
We had written one book
before called "Womenomics,"
which was essentially a look
at women in the workplace.
And I hope a lot of
you know this data,
because it's really compelling.
But there's all this
data about the more women
there are at the
top of companies,
the more money a company makes,
and just a really interesting
case for diversity that's
not based on doing things
because it's right.
It's really just because
it makes business sense.
So that's what we
were writing about.
But we were doing
all these interviews
with women who were incredibly
successful, probably
like a lot of you in this
room, and certainly looked
successful to us and confident.
And they would say things
to us like, well, I'm
about to get a promotion but
I don't think I'm qualified.
Or my bosses want
me to try this.
I don't know that
I'm ready, or even
talk about feeling like an
imposter, which was something
we all are familiar with.
But we were so struck by that.
Because I think Katty and
I both have felt frequently
that we're not
confident, or failures.
But this is crazy.
These women are so successful.
And so we started
digging into that
to see whether there
was data behind it.
And essentially,
we found there is
a lot of data to support
the notion that there's
a confidence gap
between men and women,
especially at work, not as
much in our social lives
or in our family lives
or lives with friends.
And we started to try
to look at why that is.
I mean, one of the
best pieces of data
that I like is this corporate
poll that was done that showed
that women will apply
for a job or a promotion
when we feel we have--
what percentage would you
imagine of the qualifications?
Yeah, 100-- I heard 100.
And I don't think
110 was an option.
Because definitely,
we would want 110.
And men will take the
risk at about 60%.
And of course, what we found
over time is that attitude,
it's not just about applying
for jobs or promotions.
It's about is this report ready?
Am I going to participate
in this meeting?
Am I going to do this?
Am I going to do that?
And women are constantly
judging themselves not quite
ready or not quite prepared.
And in fact, men tend to
swing the opposite way.
It's so interesting.
Columbia University has
studied this proclivity
on the part of men to kind of be
overconfident or overconfident
about their performance in
taking a test, let's say.
And they found, on average,
men are overconfident
or overestimate their
abilities by about 30%.
But what's interesting
about that,
too, is they call that
honest overconfidence.
I think for a lot of years, I
thought, that's just bravado.
These men are just faking it.
They're not faking it.
They really do have that--
I see that with my son.
They have that ability to
assess themselves differently.
And I think what we ultimately
found is that matters at work.
Confidence actually matters
in terms of success.
There's a professor who's been
studying this out at Berkeley--
confidence versus competence.
And he's found
that in many cases,
confidence trumps
competence in terms
of being valuable for
traditional success, which
we found sort of appalling.
But we realized this is a
skill women need to build.
SPEAKER: I think a lot
of us can relate to that.
And we've actually done
some internal studies here.
And I think maybe you
even wrote about this--
CLAIRE SHIPMAN: Yes.
SPEAKER: About this project
where-- and some of you
might be familiar
with this-- at Google,
where women weren't
putting themselves forward
for promotions in our
engineering teams.
And so somebody recognized that
women weren't getting promoted.
So they started to
send out emails to say,
put yourself forward.
And once women were
getting nudged to, OK, I'm
going to try, then they
recognized that they
could put themselves forward.
And the numbers shot up.
CLAIRE SHIPMAN: That's amazing.
SPEAKER: But they weren't seeing
women put themselves forward.
I think we've come a long way
since that original study.
But I think maybe we talked
about that a couple years ago.
CLAIRE SHIPMAN: We did.
No, I can't remember if
we put it in our book.
Or certainly, I talk
about that a lot.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
But I think a lot of
us can relate to that.
So as you started
to look into that,
then you wrote the
"Confidence Code."
And then do you want to just
talk a little bit about how
that evolved and thinking
about people coming up
to you about their children?
CLAIRE SHIPMAN: Well, so
we wrote the "Confidence
Code," which really
seemed to strike
a chord with a lot of women.
And the other thing I
will say about confidence,
just so we all
understand the formula--
because in the book for adults,
we got a little obsessive
about the science, the biology.
Where does it come from?
How do we get it?
Do men have a confidence
gene that women don't have?
Sort of all of these questions
about the origin questions.
And men don't, in fact,
have a confidence gene
that we don't have,
which is nice to know.
But confidence is
partly genetic, which
we thought was really weird.
And we tested our genes for
the genes they know about
now to see whether we had them.
We don't.
Katty and I are
both basket cases
in terms of confidence genes.
But it's only partly genetic.
And the bulk of
our confidence, we
build throughout the
course of our lives.
And this is so
important for women.
So confidence isn't about
feeling good or feeling
that we're valuable or how
we feel about ourselves.
Confidence heavily
involves action.
So confidence is what turns
our thoughts into action.
And that's important.
Because I think
we often get stuck
in the thinking part of that.
And we say, oh, I'm going
to think and over-think
that and not act.
But what we also found is
the creation of confidence,
it's really a virtuous circle.
You build more confidence when
you take that risk and you act.
And maybe you fail.
Maybe you struggle.
Maybe you work
through the process,
but you master something.
That's the way you
build more confidence.
So when women don't
act, they're not
stockpiling more confidence.
So that, we thought,
was pretty critical.
And what we realized is
happening with girls is--
and we got pretty obsessed also
with girls and young women.
Because we're like, gosh,
they excel at school.
They just beat the pants off
boys right now at school.
It's really people
who are worried
about education are worrying
more about boys than girls.
So why are young women
still not confident?
And what we realized is
happening-- and Carol Dweck,
who wrote the great
book, "Mindset"--
people here might be
familiar with it--
explained to us that if life
were one long grade school,
girls would rule
the world, right?
But it's not.
And the standards
change appreciably
once we're out in
the real world.
And so what happens with girls
is we become perfectionists.
We are so good early on
because of the different ways
our brains work, our higher EQ
at pleasing people, coloring
within the lines,
getting everything right,
doing everything.
And parents and
teachers encourage that.
And by the time girls
are in high school
and middle school
today, I mean, it's
worse than ever, I mean
full-blown, people-pleasing
perfectionists.
And if you're a perfectionist,
what do you not want to do?
SPEAKER: Fail.
CLAIRE SHIPMAN:
That's way too scary
to take risks if
you're a perfectionist.
You want to stay in your lane,
do what you're already good at.
And so boys still, from an
early age-- and forgive me.
You'll see that this is
a positive as I'm talking
about you men in the room--
I mean, they fail
all over the place
typically from an early age.
They just do it more naturally.
And they learn it doesn't
matter that much, which
is a powerful lesson to learn.
Girls aren't really
learning that as much.
And then you hit the workplace.
And that's what you
need to be able to do,
is take risks and fail.
It's almost as though somebody--
we educate girls in this system.
And it's like, oh,
and by the way,
we're going to require something
completely different of you
right now.
And what we found-- and a
little bit of the data we had
was that the drop for
confidence for girls
seems to happen about puberty.
And between that
and then what we
would hear from parents who
were talking to us a lot
as we would give speeches about,
yeah, this is all great for me.
But what can I do
for my daughter?
You know, this is crazy.
What's going on
with my daughter?
We just thought we wanted
to dive in and really
take a harder look at
what's happening with girls
and see if we could
just help a bit.
SPEAKER: And are there some
practical things that all of us
can think about, who first
of all, who are parents
and how we conduct
ourselves at home
and how we react to things
that happen in our own lives?
Do you have some tips on that?
CLAIRE SHIPMAN: Yes.
So if you think about
what you most want
your daughters to do--
and it's hard to do.
Because remember,
all of this pressure
about school and grades--
and it's all out there.
But you do want your kids to
build resilience and confidence
while they're still
at home with you.
And that necessarily involves
struggle and failure.
So I think the most
important thing--
and it's actually
kind of liberating
as a parent, because you
can suddenly say, oh,
as your child is striking out
the fifth time in a row at bat
or whatever it is.
And you think, oh, my god.
This is horrible.
And you have to
realize, actually,
if I can help him
through this, this
is going to be a
great life experience.
So I would say the
overarching tip
is look for ways
you can encourage
your daughters to step
outside of their comfort zones
and do things they're
really not good at
and get comfortable
being uncomfortable.
And that's going to be
different for every girl.
I mean, my daughter
loves athletics.
She's a tomboy.
I thought when we
started working on this,
I thought, oh, well,
that won't be Della.
She'll be immune to this stuff
because she's kind of sporty.
She's still a perfectionist.
Oh, I'm never going to try
out for the debate team.
I'm too scared.
Or I don't want to stand
on the stage to do this.
So you have to look
for opportunities
where you can say, try it.
The result doesn't
matter, really kind of
make them feel they
have a safe environment.
But look for areas where they
might be able to do things
where failure is OK.
And they see that they
can work through it.
SPEAKER: And do
you think about how
you might react to things
that happen in your work day
and talk about that?
CLAIRE SHIPMAN: Well, so I
think for mothers especially,
the most important thing we
can do is be good role models.
And I mean, especially
for all of you,
because it's too late for me.
I screwed up.
And it's like all over.
But please-- it's
not too late for you.
But we want a model
that we struggle too
and that we have failures.
And we have things that
are hard to deal with.
And have those
discussions with them
and say, oh, my
editor who's here--
I remember distinctly talking
to Della at one point, saying,
oh, I got notes
back from my editor.
I'm not going to want
to go through them.
There are things
she doesn't like.
Or I'm going to have to
really deal with this,
and then sort of having her
listen and talk through, well,
but that's OK.
I think overall, she likes the
book, and some of these changes
are going to make sense.
And I kind of open them
up to some of that stuff
that we deal with that's hard.
I mean, it's not our natural
inclination to want to do that.
But if they see that their
parent is trying all the time
to be perfect, then that's
really not great role modeling
for them.
And I would also say--
so we did a lot of
polling for this book.
Because we wanted more data.
And we did find, in fact,
that girls experience,
between the ages of eight and
14, a 30% drop in confidence,
really big.
Up till age eight,
girls and boys
have the same
confidence measures.
But the other thing we
found is that fathers
are better at recognizing
a lack of confidence
in their daughters
than mothers are.
So I think dads can actually
play a really important role.
Because this behavior does look
so weird to them typically,
right?
It's like, what do you mean
you're scared to do this?
It just doesn't make
sense, whereas I
think we don't like
it, but there's
part of us that understands it.
Oh, yeah, I know why
you wouldn't want
to get up on stage, totally.
So I think fathers
can do a lot, too.
SPEAKER: That's a good point.
And then you also
looked at social media.
CLAIRE SHIPMAN: Yes.
We did look at social media.
You know, look, we tried
to be realistic about it.
Because kids kind of live
on social media right now.
And for girls--
I'm going to take
a step back and say
the other thing that
happens besides a confidence
drop for girls--
and this is related--
is that at puberty,
this instinct
to ruminate or
over-think kicks in.
And that is something that
we all really probably
experience as women,
where you get that review.
And you think about the
one area of improvement
and not the rest of it,
which was great for two weeks
straight, and you know?
SPEAKER: Or years.
CLAIRE SHIPMAN: Yeah,
or years, maybe, years--
as Jen pointed out, she
still remembers that trip,
that failure in Moscow.
It's like right there,
front and center.
But this starts from
girls at puberty.
And I really was struck by that.
Because I thought, oh, my gosh.
What must that feel like?
Your brain is being hijacked
and you don't really
understand what's
happening and why you can't
stop thinking about something.
Well, what social media
does, the psychologists
talked to us about, for girls is
that it just exacerbates that.
So it's like
ruminating on steroids.
15, 20 years ago,
you might have been
able to go home, have a fight
with a friend, get a bad grade,
whatever it is.
And you're forced to put that
aside at least for a couple
of hours or overnight.
That just doesn't
happen anymore.
It just keeps going and going.
And it's amplified.
So our goal in the
book is to help
girls understand that,
understand that there are ways
you can put it down
that are realistic,
not just never use social media.
Because it's just not something
that's going to happen.
But I think also
just as importantly,
how do you use it
in a positive way?
Because there are
really powerful
ways for girls to use it.
At this age, there's this
desire to connect, to find
people who are like them.
Girls are very open at that
age to inspirational advice,
inspirational sayings,
seeing role models, people
they really admire and how
they think about things.
So I think we tried to
offer a lot of suggestions
about how they can find
their tribe that way
and really focus on
that in a positive way.
SPEAKER: And you did a
campaign with Instagram.
CLAIRE SHIPMAN: We did.
We did a great campaign
with Instagram called--
and now I'm going to blank.
We did an amazing
campaign with Instagram,
which was girls showing their--
basically, it was basically
showing your confidence--
Capture Confidence.
But show yourself
doing something
that makes you feel confident.
Don't show yourself looking
photoshopped or perfect
or having the perfect
life for something
where you're going to
get a million likes.
Show yourself doing something.
So we have a big focus
on action in the book,
but that makes you
feel confident.
And we just had a bunch of
incredible girls who helped us
with that who were very
out-of-the-box girls.
And we had a great
reaction to it.
SPEAKER: I'm curious.
The timing of this book--
oops-- I think with
Me Too movement.
I'm just curious if
you have thoughts
on this whole good
girl, don't rock
the boat, the way a
lot of us were raised.
And in light of what we're
seeing with Me Too, what
have you thought about that?
CLAIRE SHIPMAN: Yes.
Well, Me Too was exploding as
we were finishing the book--
again, as our editor
here will remember.
And we thought about, how do
we talk about this for eight
to 12-year-old girls?
Because it's not
straightforward.
But it is true that I
think what we realized
is girls are absolutely
essential to creating
a speak-up culture.
And I think one of
the biggest risks--
if we all agree that confidence
involves taking some risks--
one of the biggest risks
for them is speaking up
in a way that might mean
people don't like them,
or they're not pleasing the
person they want to please.
And so we created a
manifesto in the book,
which really has to do with--
my favorite part of it--
there are three or four bullet
points--
is it's not my job
to please people,
and I think for
girls to understand
that is not their primary
function, right, to constantly
be the person who's
going to be liked
or that adults are going
to think is wonder--
they need to learn a little
bit of bravery on that front,
if you will.
And I think once they feel
confident about speaking up,
I think that will be a big
boost for the next generation
in the workplace.
SPEAKER: We hope, yeah.
Well, we definitely
want to take questions.
So there is a mic there.
If you guys could line
up, we'll do that.
CLAIRE SHIPMAN: It will require
confidence to move to the mic
and ask that question.
SPEAKER: So do you
have any other tips
in the book that come to
mind about language, or?
Also, with social media,
just the whole idea of just
put down the phone
for a little while.
CLAIRE SHIPMAN: Right.
SPEAKER: Things
like that, I think,
that just seem so obvious.
CLAIRE SHIPMAN: We do.
SPEAKER: Just to cool off.
CLAIRE SHIPMAN: We sort
of have the 24-hour rule,
which is the cool-off rule.
We have the kind of
you can write something
but don't send it right away.
Wait a day before you send
it, which I still need
to actually employ sometimes.
I think one of my favorite
rules really is to--
we call it--
I guess it's not really get
out of your comfort zone.
I guess it's really the
rule of almost taking it,
giving yourself a time-out,
which is when you have
something scary happen to you
or you are processing a failure
and you're starting to
ruminate and over-think--
and this is the same for
adults as well as kids--
you have to get your brain away
from that for a little bit.
You literally can't
process anything
when your fear center or your
amygdala is on high alert.
So we talk about
changing the channel.
And essentially that means
watch a TV show, take a run,
eat some ice cream,
kind of let yourself
get to a different
place, read a book.
And then you can get back
in and look at things.
But I think especially
for girls to understand,
I have some control over
what's happening inside,
and here's how.
So we have kind of a
series of steps like that
that I think will be pretty
clear for parents, too.
SPEAKER: So helpful.
CLAIRE SHIPMAN: Yes?
AUDIENCE: I was
curious to know--
you were talking about some data
and polling that you had done.
I was wondering if there was
a difference in communities
of color, because there has
to be some disparities when--
especially with
parents not thinking
they're afforded the
privilege of making sure
that their kids make
mistakes that often.
CLAIRE SHIPMAN: Right.
AUDIENCE: I was just curious
to see what that looked like.
CLAIRE SHIPMAN:
You know, we did--
in the polling we
did with girls,
we did not see a big breakdown
in terms of race or ethnicity
in terms of girls' confidence.
In the polling we did, we did a
confidence poll or a confidence
quiz after our adult book came
out, where women went online.
And a lot of women went
online and took this quiz.
And we found that
African American women
were more confident generally
than white women who are more
confident than Asian women.
But the professors who
helped us with this
said to pursue that
and kind of dig
into why that is, we'd
need a larger sample size.
And we'd want to do additional
polling, which we didn't do.
But I do think there's no
question that if you look
at all of the data on something
called stereotype threat, when
you feel different--
so like you're one
of the only women on a board.
You're one of the only
women at a meeting.
African American women in a--
there are degrees of
different you might feel.
That really does
affect your confidence
and your performance.
So I think the more
things you have
in your life that make you feel
other from a larger population,
it is a real--
and I think it's important
for girls and women
to understand that.
It really does have an effect.
So it's not all you.
It's partly the society.
And I think understanding
that also allows all of us
to give ourselves a
break to some extent.
But we have a lot in the book
on girls who feel different
for a variety of reasons,
whether it's race,
whether it's their religion,
whether it's being transgender,
or whether it's--
because you're absolutely right.
I think that's an
extra burden to trying
to be fully confident.
And it's riskier
in a lot of ways.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I have a one-year-old
daughter, Rose.
And Rose has two daddies.
And you mentioned that
fathers have an important role
to play in kind of recognizing
a lack of confidence situation.
But I also heard you say
that mothers kind of maybe
have more empathy or
more understanding of how
a girl might feel.
And I was wondering,
other than surrounding her
with strong female
role models, do you
have any tips or
anecdotes about ways
to essentially bridge
that empathy gap?
CLAIRE SHIPMAN: You know--
and I should say,
and I usually say
this at the beginning
of every speech--
so we are all on a spectrum.
So not every woman is going
to be more empathetic.
Not every man is going
to be more narrow focus.
So I talk in generalities.
Because generally speaking,
those things are often true.
But it doesn't mean that men
aren't going to be empathetic.
I mean, there's really
interesting data also
that shows that men who
are the primary caregivers
and spend an enormous amount
of time around their children
actually do experience hormonal
changes and a real difference
in sort of the EQ factor.
So I think a lot
of it probably has
to do with proximity,
to some extent.
But I think that just helping
girls understand that they
can be heard is important.
And I think, again, you're
right about the role models.
Let them see people who
are like them but not so--
one psychologist said to us,
and this is why we, in the book,
we have some real girls at
the end of each chapter who
have done some amazing things.
But we specifically
chose not to focus
on a lot of girls like,
say, Malala or girls
who are just extraordinary but
who probably are going to seem
far away from what most girls,
the way they might think
about themselves, so I think
trying to find role models
who are accessible
for them and who
have done things
that are similar,
but it just seems
within reach somehow.
But my sense is you're not going
to-- if you're paying attention
to your daughter, I
don't think you're going
to have an empathy problem.
I wouldn't worry about that.
AUDIENCE: I'm
wondering if you can
talk a little bit about internal
versus external confidence.
Because I know within myself
and my friend circles,
we definitely show
ourselves very differently
than how we're feeling.
I just started working here.
This is my second week.
[APPLAUSE]
CLAIRE SHIPMAN: So
that's confident.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
Thank you.
The fake it till
you make it message
came to me from a lot of
different people, specifically
women.
And I'm wondering why
we have to fake it
if we are here in this room
and feel like we don't fully
belong until we have
to fake that we belong.
CLAIRE SHIPMAN:
You know, we have
a section in our
adult book on the does
fake it till you make it work?
And our conclusion
was maybe sometimes.
But it's actually
not the best advice.
So I will counter what you
have heard from other people.
Because first of all,
women are saddled already
with constantly feeling like
we're frauds and imposters
and faking it, and so just
adding another layer on to that
and saying, OK, now I'm going
to be someone else again.
But I think what
fake it till you
make it gets at is
that if you think back
to that formula for confidence,
often what needs to happen
is, is you have to
take that first risk.
You have to just get some
experience under your belt.
And how do you do that?
How do you get over that chasm?
And I think it's far better
to tell yourself to recognize
that you're afraid or
you're nervous to understand
that that's normal.
It would actually
be odd not to be.
So that's a completely
valid feeling.
And then just tell yourself that
I'm just going to do it afraid.
This is a phrase somebody
gave us, which is just
acknowledge you're afraid
but choose to act anyway.
And I also think that--
I don't work here so I don't
fully know the culture.
But what I've seen as
I speak in a variety
of different
corporate settings now
is it's so different than it
was even five years ago or 10
years ago.
I think people are open to more
honest conversations about how
you're feeling.
What are your struggles?
I'm nervous.
I'm not.
I've got my kids.
I'm worried about this.
I mean, I remember there was a
woman who was a mentor for me
at ABC who at one point said,
well, but part of the problem
is this other person, she
doesn't talk about her kids.
And you maybe just
have to not do that.
And I looked at her.
I said, I'm literally
incapable of doing that.
I can't do that.
I just kind of talk about
this stuff all the time.
And I think we're past
that point where you have
to pretend to be something.
I think it's all right to be
vulnerable, let people in.
And you can still be extremely
competent and successful
and actually probably relate
to people a little bit better.
SPEAKER: Yeah, be
more are authentic.
CLAIRE SHIPMAN: Yes.
SPEAKER: We actually
did a presentation
at TGIF a couple
of years ago, where
we talked about imposture
syndrome and the company.
And something like 95% of
all Googlers experience it.
So a lot of us are
feeling the same thing.
I don't belong here.
And it's pretty common.
CLAIRE SHIPMAN: Right.
Right.
Well, especially I'm sure
at a company like Google,
where it's just got
this kind of name.
And you think,
wow, why am I here?
But I would say let
authenticity trump
the sort of feeling of trying
to be something you're not--
and congratulations on the job.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry.
I just want to comment on
just the previous question.
I got a good lesson
from someone in my past
when I was faced with a
difficult decision that kind of
said and helped me try to
isolate the reasons why you're
not doing something.
And if you're left
with fear, then that's
not a good enough reason.
CLAIRE SHIPMAN: Oh,
that's great, too.
AUDIENCE: And I agree
with what was said here.
You're in very good
company if you're
feeling that you don't belong.
And you can feel pretty
safe about talking
to people about it.
So a very common sentiment in
lectures like this and talks
about books like this
is we have, I think,
a fair amount of
young parents here.
And our main concern,
especially as parents of girls,
is how do we make the
next generation better?
Like you said, we're
already kind of screwed.
We've suffered a lot of
society's influence, which
is, I think, the biggest factor
in confidence among women.
And I wanted to ask--
so right now, my oldest daughter
is only three and a half.
I feel like I have a fair
amount of influence on her.
I know that once she
enters the school
system, the amount of
influence I have will go down.
And I wanted to ask,
what's next for you?
When are we going to
see the "Confidence
Code" for schools and the
"Confidence Code" for parents?
Do you have any thoughts
in that direction?
CLAIRE SHIPMAN: Well,
we're hoping that--
we are working on a
curriculum for schools
so that they could
use this book,
and for girls especially
in middle school.
For parents, I think you'll
find when you look at it,
it's really self-explanatory in
terms of following along with.
Because it's very
much workbook-like.
It's full of quizzes and tests.
I was telling Jen that
some grown women have said,
I actually like this book
better than your adult book
because it's got the lists.
So I think we hope for parents,
it will be fairly easy.
But it's really hard
to see your kids face
all these other influences.
But again, I think you
have to, as a parent,
realize that the more you
can get out of the way
and let them experience
things and experience
problems and issues and
failures and encourage them
through that, the better
off they're going to be.
SPEAKER: Sooner
rather than later,
because it's like you want
them to have them while you're
around and you're there.
You don't want to wait for
all of that stuff to happen.
CLAIRE SHIPMAN: Well, I
think that's a good point.
The more you can
help your daughter
before she hits
middle school get
used to doing some failing--
I like to think of it that
you're going to inoculate her.
Because I mean, like middle
school is really not fun.
It's still not fun.
It really isn't.
And you can't control what
friends are going to do
and the way teachers
are going to treat you.
And so the more you can do early
on to let her fail and build up
some resilience, it's great.
And I mean, I will say the
other thing is-- and it's not
for everybody-- but there's
incredible data that
shows that athletics for
girls makes a huge difference.
I mean, there's
almost a direct link
between the longer
a girl plays a sport
and the higher rank she
reaches in the workplace.
I, of course, did no sports.
So it's like, oh, darn.
And I don't think it's
only about athletics.
It's just that
athletics creates this--
it's really a ready-made
forum in which girls can lose
and fail over and over again.
And they have no choice.
They just have to get
out there and do it.
And that might be also a debate
team or trying out for a play.
It's just the
athletics are there.
And you don't have to
think about it as much.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
CLAIRE SHIPMAN: But thank
you for your question.
AUDIENCE: So just a
little back story--
I was raised by a single mom.
And she worked in finance
pretty much my entire life.
And she was often one of the
only women in a situation.
And she's a very
confident woman.
And in turn, I've been
raised to be very confident.
But in then, I have definitely
in times been called a bitch.
I've been called domineering.
I've been told that I'm pushy.
And how do you
basically teach girls
that it's OK to be
confident without in turn
receiving that kind of feedback?
CLAIRE SHIPMAN: You know,
one thing I say, especially
honestly to young women--
and I think with girls, it's
important to start early
with that conversation.
But I think I really love
talking to young women today
because they're so
much more focused
on all of these issues
than I ever was.
And they ask a lot of questions.
But there's also
still this sense of I
want to navigate
things perfectly.
How can I avoid these issues?
So to some extent, you
won't totally avoid it.
And I think what we as
women have to understand
is there have to be
a number of women
who are willing to be
labeled pushy or a bitch
or whatever it is so
that we can finally
broaden this box of
behavior that women
have been kind of confined in.
So I try to encourage
people to kind of gird
for that battle a little
bit and realize, OK, yeah,
this is bad for you.
But it's really good
for everybody else,
what you're doing.
But I do think, again,
this piece for girls,
if the earlier we can
help them understand
that they don't need
to worry about being
liked all of the time.
I mean, I remember a
therapist once told me.
I was really worried
about some work issue.
And I said, I'm worried I'm
going to seem really mean.
And he's like,
Claire, I don't even
know what you could
do in order to sound--
and I think for most
of us, the world
is not going to hate women.
We're not in danger of heading
over to that dark side.
So I think that the more we can
encourage girls to understand
they don't have to have
everybody pleased all the time,
it will become more normal.
Your straight-forward,
I'm sure, ambitious,
leadership-like behavior will
be viewed that way instead of,
wow, she's pushy.
But thank you for doing that.
AUDIENCE: So I have a
nine-year-old daughter.
And she's been exhibiting
a little bit more--
like less fear of doing
something at school that she
would fail at but fear
of physical things,
like an elevator or
like going over a bridge
or something like that.
And did you notice that?
Is that part of this
for young girls?
CLAIRE SHIPMAN:
You know, I think
what it tends to happen at
puberty is that there's this--
and forgive me for
doctors or scientists
in the room, because I'm
really short-handing this--
but what happens with our brains
and with the influx of estrogen
is we're just even
so much more aware.
There's this hyper
awareness that
happens of people's
expressions, what
we see around a room, what it
might feel like to realize,
oh, we're in the elevator.
Puberty is really an
exceptional period that way.
So it's not uncommon.
And I've heard other
people talk about that.
And I think a lot of the
tips we have in the book
are heavily based on
cognitive behavioral therapy.
Because essentially, the way
to get comfortable taking risks
is really to create different
thinking habits, habits
in the way we think essentially.
And that's cognitive
behavioral therapy.
And so a lot of
the steps in here
in terms of acclimating
yourself to risk-taking I think
would be really helpful.
You sort of go
through this process.
What's the worst thing
that's going to happen?
Then you do step two.
And then you do step three.
And you can almost even
create a ladder of things.
And it makes a difference.
What's really helpful for
parents, by the way too,
is to have this
broad view over time
that your kids will not have.
And actually, it's really
hard for me to have.
I have barely any
memory anymore.
But if you can
literally think back
and say, oh, do you
remember six months ago how
you were afraid to do X?
And look at what you've done
now and sometimes tie some
of those things together.
That's really, really powerful.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for being here.
So I'm curious.
It seems that when we have a
lot of these conversations,
we talk about how
to provide woman
with traits that
are traditionally
more male or masculine.
And I'm wondering whether you
in the course of your research
saw the other side of
that, people talking
about tips for boys, for men.
And then generally,
it's my point of view,
we're not having that
conversation as much.
And you don't see
books on the shelves
about that, and
why that is maybe,
and if you think we should
have that conversation, too.
CLAIRE SHIPMAN: You
know, I do think--
honestly, especially
in the wake of Me Too--
I think we could
use a book for boys.
I could use one instead
of having these really
awkward conversations with my
16-year-old son about wait,
well, do you think
you're going to kiss her?
Wait, and talk about all this.
I need a book.
But I think there
are two things.
So ideally, we are not
saying in urging women
to think about whether
they're confident
or not, or girls,
be more like men.
And so we try to be very
explicit about that actually
in both books.
I think it's really important
for girls to feel as confident
as they are competent.
So we got into this
issue with a scientist
who studies confidence in
rats at Cold Spring Harbor.
I didn't know there were
confident and non-confident
rats.
But there are.
Because we really wanted to
drill down on the idea of, OK,
what is the perfect amount
of confidence to have?
If we assume women tend to
underestimate their abilities,
men tend to overestimate,
what do you really want?
And he said ideally, to make
great decisions in life,
you want your confidence as in
line with your competence as
possible.
Because that is useful.
But actually, it's useful
to have a teeny bit more
confidence because that
pushes you to do things.
That's the kind of
boost you get for doing.
So I think confidence, the trick
for women and men and gender
and everything, is that
confidence can be expressed
in a lot of different ways.
So we're not really talking
about "Mad Men" style behavior,
like, oh, I'm going to be
the first one in the room
and the loudest one at
the meeting and the person
telling everybody what to do.
And that doesn't have to be
your style of confidence.
That's not really
even confidence.
That's just behavior.
And it is behavior we've come
to accept as confident behavior.
Because generally
speaking, that's
the kind of behavior
exhibited by the people who
created the workplace.
And so there is
something to the fact
that the workplace was
created with men in mind.
I think that the norms will
benefit from a big change.
And I think that is
a conversation that
has to come from the top down.
Because that's
really a conversation
about what does a
leader look like?
Are we really being inclusive
about everybody's leadership
qualities?
Are we recognizing that
leadership qualities--
women bring very different
skills to the table.
But we will never bring
those skills to the table
if we're not willing to
say, I deserve a promotion.
So to me, that's not a
male or female asset.
That's actually just
I recognize that I'm
qualified and competent.
But that was a
really long answer.
The short answer is we
need more books on boys.
And I think it would
be really useful.
Because I think boys
and EQ is critical.
Boys need to kind of have
a lot more of those skills
that girls and women have.
And I think everybody
would be happier.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
I think when you were talking
about bringing your whole self
to work and not being afraid
to talk about what's going on
with your family, I think that
those are some of the things
that everybody can learn from.
CLAIRE SHIPMAN: Yes.
Yeah, exactly.
Speaking of boys and men, hello.
AUDIENCE: It was exactly what
I wanted to ask actually.
CLAIRE SHIPMAN: Oh, good.
AUDIENCE: I have
a girl and a boy.
And I think my girl will
definitely enjoy the book.
But I can't show it
to my boy, you know?
So yeah, if it at least was
called the "Confidence Code,"
maybe I could give it to him.
CLAIRE SHIPMAN: Right.
Right.
But is your boy-- do you feel
like he's confident or lacks
confidence?
AUDIENCE: In some areas, he is.
But I see so many things where
he is afraid to take the risk.
CLAIRE SHIPMAN: Yes.
AUDIENCE: And he could
benefit from it as well.
CLAIRE SHIPMAN: Yes.
SPEAKER: Well, I think
you should read the book.
And it will definitely
help you with both genders.
Because I have one of each.
And it was super helpful.
CLAIRE SHIPMAN:
Yeah, it is useful.
I mean, look, I've had
a lot of men come up
and say, look, we
all over-think.
We're all scared of risks.
We feel this way, too.
And of course men feel this way.
I think the biggest difference
is that men typically
don't go on to be
perfectionists,
who spent a lot of wasted time
on things when they could--
and also, I've had a couple men
say, you know, I get scared.
I get nervous.
I don't want to take the risk.
But I act anyway.
But there's still this
propensity, this push
to act that men often have and
that then results in learning.
But I think, again, talk
to that woman right there--
I'm kidding-- for
a book for boys.
Think about that.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
I have a seventh grader, a girl.
And I think what you
said really resonated.
When she was young,
she was fearless.
She ran for class president
and lost to a boy.
But she was gung-ho.
But now, she's changed.
And I think she definitely--
maybe her peer group of girls
are really into looks,
really into beauty.
She's looking at the
mirror all the time,
looking for shopping stuff.
So I feel like
her peer group now
is kind of influencing her
away from being fearless,
trying new things.
And she's on the
phone all the time--
iPhone all the time, talking
to her friends, chatting.
So any tips about
how to steer her away
from a peer group of
other girls who maybe also
like not exhibiting competence
and just focusing on
looks and so on?
CLAIRE SHIPMAN: Yeah.
You know, it's hard.
Because especially when
they get to be that age,
their friends matter to them so
much more than their parents.
And almost everything
we say is suspect.
I mean, my 13-year-old
daughter is just really,
really difficult. She's not
going to be watching this,
is she?
This is going to be awful.
But I think that what
you can do as a parent is
talk a lot about the things
that are valuable, the fact
that it's OK to stand out.
It's OK to be different.
Look for people who might be
interesting role models for her
and who are exhibiting some of
this breaking out of the pack
behavior or focus less on--
we really try in the
book to get into this.
Don't focus as much
on what you look like.
Focus on what you're doing.
Judge yourself by
what you're doing.
And for girls, I think
that's very powerful.
But for you as the
parent, you have
to find the right messenger.
Because you're probably
not the right messenger.
So you have to be
really subtle about it.
I mean, and maybe
the book is something
to use and talk about.
But maybe there are a lot
of great things on YouTube.
There are great sort of
inspirational channels
people have created that
talk a lot about failure
and being fearless for girls.
The other thing that
you can really, I think,
get middle school
girls hooked on
is get them mad about something
and get them to kind of feel
this passion about something,
whether it's animal
welfare or the fact that
their favorite sporting goods
store doesn't stock women's
basketball shoes, which
got my daughter in a rage,
and then tie that to what
do you want to do about it.
So that if you can find ways
where they get engaged--
and girls and women especially
have this drive often
to be focused on issues that
are bigger than themselves--
missions, causes.
And they can feel more
naturally confident diving
into that stuff.
So maybe look for
something like that you
can get her engaged in.
SPEAKER: I love that.
CLAIRE SHIPMAN: Good luck.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I have a nine-year-old daughter
as well, and in some ways,
a total risk taker.
I mean, she's the first
one to go off the zip line
and whatever.
She's super comfortable
with risk in that way.
The piece that I find
really interesting, though,
sort of as a weird
paradox to me,
is she's very, very
uncomfortable with being
embarrassed in front of people.
And so she does play a sport.
She plays softball.
And just even last week, she
was destroyed because she didn't
get a hit the whole game.
And I tried to do the, it's OK.
Even the best players,
even the pros don't--
I mean, all the
usual stuff, right?
So I guess my question is,
is there certain language
or certain ways to--
I mean, god forbid I try to
give the pep talk about failing.
And you didn't fail
because you got up.
And you bat.
And you tried and whatever.
CLAIRE SHIPMAN: Right.
Right.
AUDIENCE: It's not effective.
CLAIRE SHIPMAN: No, that it
really pisses them off, right?
AUDIENCE: Oh, dear god.
CLAIRE SHIPMAN: That's
never going to work.
AUDIENCE: It makes
it so much worse--
I mean, total shut
down, no conversation,
to the point where
she wants to quit
and doesn't want to
play again next weekend.
So I'm just wondering, is there
different language to use?
Maybe it's a different time.
Don't say it in the moment.
I don't know.
I'm just wondering,
what's the right way
in to get a more
receptive person?
CLAIRE SHIPMAN: I'm not
the world's biggest expert
on sports conversations.
I found it incredibly
painful with my kids.
I was like, oh, my god.
Because I felt like I
internalized everything
they're feeling.
And I feel it five
times more than they do.
So I'm not a great
passive parent.
But what I see is that
with this or anything else,
you just have to
think about your job
as being as calm and unemotional
about it as possible.
The more emotional they
are, the less you are.
And it's really hard to do.
And you almost have to
treat it like, yeah.
Yeah, that must
not have felt good.
You know, you kind of don't
try to do the opposite.
Oh, it will be better next time.
But just say, yeah, I hear you.
And in a lot of ways, what
we found talking to cognitive
therapists and people,
you cannot process.
She has to go through--
when kids are upset,
they have to go through
that, I'm really upset.
I'm grieving.
My fear center is firing.
And you need to think about,
how do I get her brain
to get out of that zone?
Because when it's out of
that zone later the next day,
she can then--
oh, look at this video.
And you can talk about
this other softball
player who failed 100 times,
like a day or two later.
But in that moment,
the best thing to do
is just don't you want to lie
in bed, get some ice cream?
Here's a book.
Well, here's a
movie, and just kind
of acknowledge it and try
to help her through it
and treat it like--
I mean, the other thing I've
seen with dads a lot more--
because I'm not good at this.
But maybe there are
great sports moms, too.
It's like you take it in stride.
It doesn't need to be
over-thought, which
again, really hard for me,
because I'm an over-thinker.
But I feel you.
And don't let her quit.
SPEAKER: You talked
about over-thinking.
But you also talked
about, in your book,
about over-preparing.
And you talked about women.
And I definitely observed
that when I was in TV,
that the women anchors
would over-prepare.
And the men-- and I did
research for both genders.
And I see that in the
workplace here as well.
I'm just wondering what
you saw in the research
about the over-preparing
and what that was about.
CLAIRE SHIPMAN: You
know, over-preparing,
I find I can really relate to.
Because being a perfectionist,
a people pleaser,
an over-preparer, I
realize now once we
started studying confidence,
what a waste of time
that has been.
And I think that's what bugs me.
It's not that I didn't have
a great job in journalism.
Or yes, I've written a book.
But it's just more
like, wow, I could
have been doing even more.
And I wouldn't have been quite
as stressed out about it.
And I actually found--
I had somebody go back.
I don't know if I
told you this story.
But I was so curious about
the over-preparation,
because I spent a
couple years being
the only woman on the
political panel on George
Stephanopoulos's show.
And I thought, god, I
think these guys are
speaking a lot more than I am.
And I always thought
that every week.
I think they're going on longer.
I feel like I'm just cutting.
But I wasn't sure.
We went back and measured
a year's worth of shows.
And I had talked 30% less.
And I was constantly
over-prepared.
You know, I would prepare
it this way and that way
and just make sure-- but then
I didn't want to stray off
of what I had prepared.
I felt like, well, no.
I know these things.
But I'm not going to jump in
with an additional comment
because I might not be right.
And it's so limiting.
SPEAKER: So did you do the
research after you were on--
were you still on the show
when you did the research?
CLAIRE SHIPMAN: No.
SPEAKER: OK.
CLAIRE SHIPMAN: I did it as
we were writing the book.
I got all the transcripts.
And it was really
sort of surprising.
But Christine Lagarde
said that to us, too.
SPEAKER: Yes.
CLAIRE SHIPMAN:
She said that she--
that was a kind of
shocking moment for us.
We had a great dinner with her.
She's an incredibly
confident woman.
But she even said, I think
one of the ways I lack
confidence is I over-prepare.
I never want to be
caught off guard.
I prepare upside
down and inside out.
And Angela Merkel and I have
talked about this a lot,
how we both over-prepare.
And we're like, what?
SPEAKER: OK.
So we're in good company.
CLAIRE SHIPMAN: Yeah,
we're in good company.
But it doesn't mean it's
a great use of our time.
SPEAKER: So have
you experimented
with maybe just leaning back
a little and not doing that?
CLAIRE SHIPMAN: Definitely.
SPEAKER: OK.
CLAIRE SHIPMAN: I created
rules for myself about,
when I was still doing
a lot more "Good Morning
America," which
pieces were just,
OK, this piece, I'm going
to spend two hours on.
I would literally have
to give myself a limit.
Because especially working
for "Good Morning America,"
I could potentially
work all night.
I literally could work
all night on something
and often wanted to.
But then I'd have my whole
team working all night.
And people weren't that happy.
And I was really
tired the next day.
So I had to kind of
create little rules.
SPEAKER: We do that
a lot in our office.
CLAIRE SHIPMAN: Do you?
SPEAKER: Yes, we could
all work here all night.
And you will never
finish all your work.
But at a certain
point, is it really
worth it to keep doing that?
So I think we-- oh,
we have one more.
Yay.
CLAIRE SHIPMAN: Oh, good.
SPEAKER: OK.
This will be our last question.
AUDIENCE: I was
like, might as well.
So this might not be
confidence for girls,
but I'm going to ask anyway.
So my mother raised me to
be very confident and more
confident than she
was as a child.
So I was just wondering,
when you grow up that way
and then you start being hyper
aware of the lack of confidence
other women are
giving young girls,
or you were given yourself
after you reflected now
that you're older, how do you
go back and talk to the older
women about it and
their lack of confidence
and how they are perpetuating
that cycle, especially
your grandma or
your mom, and having
that conversation with older
women that were in your life
without making them feel
like, oh, you messed me up
or anything like that,
without being disrespectful?
And then also, the
second part to that
is seeing other young
girls in your family
being raised that way and
then trying to stop it
but not disrespecting
their parents also--
so I guess it's like
a two-part question.
CLAIRE SHIPMAN: Yeah,
that is so tricky.
Well, hand them the book.
So you don't have
to take the blame.
I think that's one
area, especially
with family members--
I say, don't worry
about being liked.
With family, I
think you still have
to worry about being liked.
Because you don't
want to create a rift.
But I think maybe
the way to do it
is to just talk about the new
research that's out there.
And it's so interesting that,
in fact, it's really important
to encourage girls to fail.
Who knew?
And isn't this great?
And try to bring them
along and make them
see that it was their idea.
Because I think it is
hard to revisit parenting.
I'm really dreading this
moment with my kids,
by the way, when
they come to me.
And they're like,
what did you do to me?
SPEAKER: But we just have
to say we tried our best.
CLAIRE SHIPMAN: Yeah,
we tried our best.
But I think if you would start
it as a discussion about--
I mean, and that's one thing
we've been really focused
on in both of these
books, is that there's
a lot of data about this.
We've focused on the
data and the science.
Because I think for
a lot of people--
although my daughter
is like, if I
hear you use the word
research one more time,
I'm going to kill you.
Is this some of your
crazy research, Mom?
But most people will
understand that there's
meaning to it if there's
some science behind it
and some data.
And I think that can
take the sting out of it.
It's not just judgment.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
CLAIRE SHIPMAN: But
great question, sure.
SPEAKER: Thank you
so much, Claire.
CLAIRE SHIPMAN: My pleasure.
SPEAKER: I learned a lot.
And the book is great.
I highly recommend it.
Thank you so much.
CLAIRE SHIPMAN: Thank you.
My pleasure.
[APPLAUSE]